IT'S USEFUL FOR HIM IS PRETTY
EFFECTIVE AND I THINK THAT'S WHY
HE GOT THE APPLAUSE THAT HE DID.
>> Juan: GREG, IF YOU HAD TO
PICK SOMEBODY, AND I KNOW YOU
WATCHED --
>> Greg: EVERY MINUTE OF IT.
>> Juan: WHO WOULD YOU SAY WON
WON?
>> Greg: THE MOST MEMORABLE
WILL BE TULSI.
HITTING KAMALA IN THE KNEE, IT
WAS THE MOST MEMORABLE THING.
I DO HAVE -- THE GUY THAT HIT
CARRIGAN.
>> Juan: I THOUGHT, I WILL GET
CRITICIZED BUT SHE WAS A FASHION
STATEMENT LAST NIGHT.
>> Greg: YOU CANNOT COMPLEMENT
ON HER CLOTHING.
YOU KNOW WHAT, A COUPLE THINGS.
I DON'T LIKE THE AUDIENCE
REACTION TO THINGS BECAUSE THEY
REACT TO WHAT IS INTERESTING OR
EXCITING AND NOW IT IS IMPORTANT
SO WHEN SOMEBODY ZINGS SOMEBODY
YOU GET THIS -- THE KOOL-AID
LINE THE COURT USED, WASN'T THAT
CREATIVE OR INTERESTING BUT IT
FELT LIKE YOU NEEDED APPLAUSE.
TO YOUR POINT, 2009,
PRESIDENT OBAMA WAS SEEN AS A
PROGRESSIVE HERO, TEN YEARS
LATER HE IS NOW CONSIDERED A
REPUBLICAN.
OBAMACARE IS A RIGHT WING PLOT
BUT THE ATTACKS ON OBAMA REFLECT
AN ACTUAL FACT, TRUMP IS ONLY
BEEN PRESIDENT FOR THREE YEARS,
THE MAJOR PROBLEMS THEY ARE
DISCUSSING, WHETHER IT IS
IMMIGRATION OR HEALTH CARE,
LET'S TALK DEFICITS, SO IT JUST